and so when you think about this idea of
like a decentralized version being
better um talk through a little bit so
there's the lack of control uh there's
this idea of like pulling on the
community
what else is there that you see as the
value of having it decentralized
yeah so um you know generally speaking
uh you know when i say decentralized in
social media uh i really mean actually
putting your content on a blockchain
like we work on the dso blockchains
designed to store social uh social data
and build social apps on and so what
that means is
uh essentially you make uh make an
account that account's actually a public
private key and everything that you do
goes on chain just like if you were
sending and receiving bitcoin on on the
bitcoin blockchain or doing d5 on
ethereum right so but again it's for
social right we're moving that
disruption from just financial
applications to social and so what
happens is when you follow someone uh
that goes on chain when you make a post
that goes on chain uh and um the benefit
of that is basically that uh any app
that wants to build on top of that chain
can actually get access to that open
fire hose of content um and start
building more efficient apps more
efficient feeds um so that's what i'm
talking about when uh you know i'm
talking about decentralizing social
media it's putting the follow graph the
content the engagement the likes uh and
then all that other stuff actually on a
blockchain
got it and so when you start to think
about let's take twitter as kind of the
the current event situation if you will
uh if you were elon and you actually got
control of twitter uh which is still un
unclear whether he will be able to
successfully do that or not what do you
think he should do like what what would
you do with twitter if uh if it had all
these users but it's definitely
centralized hierarchical uh and kind of
as far away from what we're talking
about as it could be
it's a great question and i think the
first thing you have to ask yourself is
do you care about the twitter share
price
because if you care about the twitter
share price then i actually think the
ads driven business model that it has
today is probably the most efficient for
extracting value from its network so
what that means basically is twitter
runs what i call an ads driven business
model and that means that when you make
a post on twitter they own that post and
they don't let anyone else build an app
on top of it the only way that other
people will see the posts that you make
on twitter are if you use twitter's app
and the reason why they do that is
because if they were to allow someone
else a third party to run an app on
their content they wouldn't be able to
monetize that app they can't show ads as
effectively on apps they don't control
and so the ad driven business model
results in extreme centralization it
results in twitter needing to basically
consolidate all of the content uh and
only allow its app on top of it so that
it can be a broker between advertisers
and its users through that app right so
if you care about twitter's share price
if you care about profits then um
breaking that model is extremely risky
because um it's kind of hard to make
more money uh uh directly um you know or
rather you might be able to but it's
risky so uh if you don't care about
share price the thing that creates more
value not about extracting value
creating value for society
is actually if you open up that content
and allow anybody to build on it so in
particular twitter doesn't have to say
we're going to be the only ones who make
an app we could actually let anybody
build an app on top of twitter's
database uh and actually what's funny is
most social networks actually started
open that in that way so facebook and
twitter started open to build their
networks and when they were in their
growth phase but the problem is that
open uh
model uh at least in the centralized
world pre-blockchain uh wasn't very
monetizable so while it's good for
actually building a large network and
creating maximum value for users you
can't actually extract as much value
when you're letting any app in the world
any any developer in the world build
content on your block uh on your uh
database uh the thing that finally
changes that for the first time and it's
a new business model and it's a post i
wrote on nattertheory.com that just went
out today uh the thing that changes that
is the fact that blockchains can
integrate money with social when you can
integrate money with social uh you can
have a different business model than ads
that allows you to have an open uh
platform like a blockchain uh but you're
making money in a different way that
actually can make you more money than
you made before and i know that's a
little bit high level but i've been
talking for for a minute here so i just
want to give it back to you so i think
that i can go into it no i think this
difference between do you care about the
share price or do you not is really
important right um and elon publicly did
say that uh this isn't about economics
for him it's about free speech um and so
that would suggest he doesn't care about
the share price let's hold that as the
uh kind of assumption here um
but when you think about that i also
wonder how important revenue then is if
you don't care about share price maybe
that means that in the short term you
can just you know tank it right you just
don't care it's private whatever
uh but
is it important to have revenue so like
you know one of the things that uh i
said is if all you literally cared about
was the free speech then like buy
twitter bring it private fire you know
90 of the staff basically outside of
like the core engineering team uh and
open source as much of it as possible
and like good luck everyone let's go as
a community and my guess is that like
some pretty cool interesting things
would come out of that the question
becomes do you need revenue at all
to actually make that sustainable or
could it operate as a truly open source
project where you know in the bitcoin
community for example there's grants and
things like that that help fund some of
the development but there is no revenue
model uh that goes to the the kind of
core team how do you think about the
importance of revenue in a world where
you like open source a product like
twitter
yeah i mean so i actually think that you
need a business model that makes money
for certain actors in the ecosystem in
order for the model to be sustainable so
if nobody is making money um i think the
thing is going to fall into into
disrepair right i think you have to have
some people making money um and it's
good to start with your example of
bitcoin right on uh with bitcoin um on
the protocol you know no one uh actively
gets money for developing bitcoin
protocol but there's an application
layer on top of bitcoin uh that are
that's exchanges uh you know that allow
you to trade and and all kinds of other
things uh lending platforms that do make
money right they make money on fees they
make money on you doing stuff with your
bitcoin on that application layer uh and
so and that's actually gives them an
incentive to make sure that bitcoin
works the bitcoin functions obviously
the people who own bitcoin have an
incentive and some of the the uh biggest
you know development teams are funded by
people who own a lot of bitcoin so you
definitely need some kind of thing that
makes money uh and brings it back into
developing and investing in the network
uh the question is how do you do that uh
with with a social network versus uh uh
uh something like bitcoin um and i think
that uh that actually brings us back to
what would i do if i were to own twitter
right opening up twitter's content and
allowing anyone to build on it lacks
that uh incentive to actually keep
developing the network right because how
are you making money right you know you
could charge developers for uh you know
for like you know using your api in
their apps but that's probably i
actually doubt that's necessarily going
to make you enough money to uh to even
keep the lights on necessarily right so
you really need something that's more
efficient and that's actually where
blockchain comes in right so the thing
that blockchains are really good at and
the reason why uh actually fully
disrupting the architecture of twitter
from a centralized server to a
blockchain can really uh
pay dividends which is that blockchains
are really good at mixing money and
other things in this case social right
so when you build social media on a
blockchain you get access to completely
new product features uh that you can
transition to a fee based model a fee
per transaction based model rather than
uh uh just um you know charging
developers or ads like it is today and
the way that works is you basically have
uh micro transactions or macro
transactions that you couldn't do with
the traditional payment rails so nfts
are the most example uh the biggest
example but they're actually uh not
necessarily the biggest right you
actually want something that's more
integrated with social uh so there's you
know creator coins that are tied
people's reputation speculating on a
post you know speculating on how popular
it's going to be these kinds of product
features you could actually maybe charge
enough fees that you have enough of
incentive to maintain the network hey
you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time